center of the lap
bring the right hand into the center of
the lap Palms facing up and the
and breathe out
breathe in
it diverts attention away from these
dangerous political agendas in order to
project Modi as the spiritual wise Elder
and and I think that's really dangerous
because how easy it is to fall for it
[Music]
foreign
not only to be healthy
happy
but also do we kind to ourselves and
each other
[Music]
Modi is a creator of spectacles and so I
think people should keep in mind the
spectacle of when
far right governments and political
leaders
appropriate yoga and spirituality to
conceal
these
violent ethnonationalist and Colonial
agendas
[Music]
more these construction of international
yoga day serves this tool of historical
revisionism because on the one hand he's
saying it's a secular holiday and it's a
holiday that honors ancient India's gift
to the world
the nation of India is 75 years old also
within the subcontinent of South Asia
and India there are many different
diverse religious groups spiritual
groups indigenous groups and so he's
kind of constructing this monolithic
stagnant cultural and religious identity
and erasing then indigenous tribal
spiritual even castopressed bellat
contributions
to yoga philosophy
foreign